I want to start this off with mmm just
giving a a shout out to Mitzi shore I
know right he says all the sad she
passed me at the comments tour in 2006
might have been 2005 and it's always an
honor and she's I mean she was sick then
she's on Mount Rushmore for comedy well
Mitzi was the one who would find people
she'd find all columbic sand give them
advice that would change the way they
did things and she was you know cuz she
loved stand-up like out there the legend
is that I didn't Pauly Shore even talked
about this when Pauly would be crying in
the crib she let him cry she was like
just you know he'll help it'll make him
a better comic homeboy you know that's
my attention Oh Mike's gotta get my
attention and Pauly would tell stories
about he did this thing on MADtv about
having her she dated guys and she had
some dude that you know she would bring
she brought home and there was just a
giant fight and Thanksgiving and it's
one of the funniest [ __ ] stories ever
and it was all true but it was hilarious
it was the first time I had to say it as
a comic I was 20 I wasn't a comic really
but I was 27
Pauly Shore did this on national TV and
told a real story about his mom and her
disastrous date and how they were
throwing food at the guys you fight that
to me Mitsy might have been he goes I'm
Pauly Shore while those are and and he
tells the story and the first time I
went you can tell the truth and be funny
oh yeah you can tell the truth of who
you are and tell a real story and be
really personal and it's tragic it's
[ __ ] tragic the point and relate to
it now it's hilarious and dude it he
brought the house down
really he brought the house down Pauly
Shore is it good yeah and and his mom
you know his mom had a lot to do with
that about Pauly growing up like that
around comedy to--'cause was here to
change his name from Ned Holness to
Carlos Mencia changed his career every
time at you literally man that the
amount of people that she's touched
through comedy in the Comedy Store and
you look at the names and the
environment she's created at the Comedy
Store it's there's no there's no Club
like the Comedy Store no I mean I've
performed it every club in New York City
I've spent a lot of time in New York
City my formative years as a comic was
New York City there's no club like the
Comedy Store there's nothing the
darkness like how dark it was the
original room it was almost like she
created a space where if you could do
comedy there you could do comedy
anywhere and it's and look at it now and
what what is unknown neurological
disorder for years she had something
similar to Parkinson's so she used to
shake so when she passed me yeah in 2005
she was shaking like you could see her
shake talk about the again past because
now who does it now now I think it's
Adam and a group people but Mitzi was
the one who had to pass you as a regular
so I would show was a big deal yep and
when I got there Joe Rogan and
recommended me I got up I had five
minutes four minutes that's all you had
at the time and I had never performed
where I couldn't see an audience so it
threw me I was in a I was a vacuum and I
was doing [ __ ] and he or yep and they
didn't pass me and then I met I met said
dude you got a you got a perform permit
see I'm gonna sit with her and make her
watch you and he sat watched me I did
well but it was only four minutes five
minutes that's a short time very hard
four minutes yeah and that's all she
that's all she would give you at the
time is four or five that's it she could
tell right away yeah and I did this I
did my Israeli porn site they could do
my bed I make a very nice you know and
she was laughing apparently yeah and I
came over and said hi to her and I
squeezed her shoulder and I was past
she said you passed and she didn't say
it Ahmed said I was like you're good
you're good and I went wow that's cool
man Wow I said I thought I [ __ ] have
been passed at a class very hard to get
passed at any club in LA very very tough
there I hired TV credits I'd been doing
stand-up and I still couldn't really get
passed I remember I went to the Laugh
Factory and they didn't past me how long
did you were you doing comedy before you
got you you did that last ten years yeah
Jesus yeah
ten years man I had already done
Letterman we did it dry before that
right I had tried before he tried
multiple oh yeah oh yeah didn't get
passed twice and then I got passed the
third time and it was just a you know
those names up on that wall there are
very few people that have there are paid
regulars at the comics all very very few
and and so I was part of this special
fraternity yes and that's when I started
performing all the time there once you
start once you got path yeah and by that
time I was a little bit different a lot
of people cuz I had already had my you
know I'd already been a pretty good
comic I'd already yeah
you had some credentials yeah and I your
so and I was good I was selling on the
road already it's not like you do almost
yeah I was selling but not well I was
taking very small rooms on the road cuz
I didn't do the road remember for years
I was an actor and I didn't do the road
really become a road guy so 2006 like a
traditional time yeah never I never went
away
never went away so I was 2006 and then I
did I think it was C I went to Kansas
City and I did stand-up for the first
time and and I remember I was really
nervous decided to an hour and I did
really really well this woman was
laughing so hard and I went oh my god
this is home yeah this is why I belong
yep and I was it I never looked back but
you know again someone like yeah Mitzi
shore let me throw some names out Robin
Williams Richard Pryor David Letterman
Jay Leno David Letterman used to park
cars okay at the copy store yeah Jay
Leno Jim Carrey Chris Rock are sending a
haul Roseanne Barr they I don't know if
you've heard of those names but that
shows peoples who spent their vote of
years another for Matias Joe Rogan Joe
Rogan Rogan starting their when he was
27 when he was a fledgling comic Jeff
Ross bill burr spent a lot of time there
I mean and and any comic people forget
it uh Howie Mandel there yeah I always
think of him as like you know funniest
American videos where the [ __ ] it is
he's a killer last comic store whatever
the show he's on America gets talent
yeah no no monster of a cop well how
about that monster how about this I'm
doing it I'm doing a thing in Thousand
Oaks it's a charity and it's for the
school and it's all parents I go out and
I [ __ ] like I don't know
was 35 minutes I was just on one I
killed it and I go and I murdered Howie
Mandel had to follow me I was like good
luck good luck with that dude cuz I
think yeah he's having Mendell until
such a nice guy by the way yeah
always so nice to me and I was but I was
like you're not gonna fall I mean that's
tough to follow bro and also yeah man
don't stand up Yeah right
Howie men don't need to know he [ __ ]
destroyed yeah he destroyed and I went
oh my god and I was like oh of course a
legend well of course no these Howie and
as people go from you know though all
the kids think Oh Eddie Murphy let's get
this Nutty Professor well no that's
that's a that's a monster even women Oh
Neal Brennan said it about how about
Eddie Murphy what he made up just on one
movie he made a billion dollars as a
donkey yeah a billion dollars as a
donkey right don't get it twisted you
he's so prodigiously talented you want
any Murphy to show up and to stand up
right now go ahead okay he'll crush they
say he they say he has um like barbecues
for over in like parties for big game
stuff his house all the time like every
week and Chris Rock and David Spade said
they would go to his house and they'd be
at his house and jut and it'd be the
biggest comics you know in the world
like the funniest people you've ever
seen and they're killing it right now
and I said Eddie Murphy just around the
house is funnier than everyone in the
room and Chris Rock goes dude we tried
Tom please just do just do one like
giant show he's like nah man I'm not
into anymore he was you're the funniest
person of all time I think he's afraid I
mean I've heard that he's afraid that
he's going to get a lot of gay backlash
because he was so homophobic but yeah
he's yet he's also he likes he likes to
dabble in that side really oh yeah well
I mean come on
he picks up trans best trainings I mean
it takes up till you sure's dressed his
cut you with dicks
well he got caught did he he got his hot
[ __ ] looked at all God how do you
slander Eddie Murphy's name what we're
talking is no and his and his his old
stand-up was so aggressive and so anti
so homophobic but they all knew and so
he doesn't want to get called out and
I've heard
that from a pretty reliable source that
that's one of them he just doesn't want
to deal with it because it would be
embarrassing to her but you know
transgender prostitute yeah well yeah
and and by the way they used to always
they'd see him pick up and he would go
into his gate so they couldn't follow
him or is it a bummer I mean no I don't
care I don't give a [ __ ] I don't care I
mean I'm just gonna deal with the
backlash yeah yeah but yeah he's a beast
and of course he should be doing oh my
god is he a monster smokes a lot of weed
apparently some people that do yeah
there's like a sheik in the lane alright
I think I thought he lived in LA I know
he had the biggest house one of the
biggest houses you suck but he's still
here I'm sure he's has one here but I
think yours I get an aerial yeah
probably getting it or you're tired of
LA after a while get an aerial view of
Eddie Murphy's house you know does it
beat Evander Holyfield's it's one of the
biggest houses in California
I mean Bel Air he looks like a sheik by
the way internet super slow today so
it's gonna take time for this that that
covers a lot of grow my god what is that
it it's right in Bel Air somewhere it's
like you know I mean thank God she knows
houses in you are so stupid yeah well
when you're Eddie Murphy I'm I expected
me live in a house like that yeah yeah
he's never stopped working four levels
went a long time without a hit and then
Shrek came along he was the donkey dude
here's some classics he has some 20
million I figured be more than that ah
yeah maybe that's who knows what year
that is now I bet it's worth more
probably
Jesus Christ that is a man Chong it's a
man home that's a bachelor mansion
it's a mansion and he's got that big
pool and it'll it'll [ __ ] your life up
like if you're looking at houses and
then some was like it'll come this house
and it's just like you don't know the
price and it's double the price that you
can afford and you're a cool god damn it
man they got to go back to look in your
well it's really funny sad because I I
when I was looking at houses I went made
the mistake of going to look for houses
with my brother-in-law I'm a sister and
they were looking at how this is back a
different animal I mean
looking at houses that were you know I
mean I'd go into the kitchen and I was
like stop [ __ ] and then the view and
you'd be like huh wait a minute I think
money bye-bye your happiness yeah where
you go there you go
but that viewed it I would never leave
you know used to be yeah and then uh it
and and then you know anyway but but so
then you go back and then you're looking
at your houses you're looking at your
house that's like if your mind if that's
like if you're buying a if you're just
in line for like a looking for a car
you're like looking for a Civic and they
pull around a Ferrari like I guess I
think we're spin they tell you around
the block eh
all right it's cool man yeah but here's
the Civic League ah I know well I see I
didn't know the difference Joey used to
Rogen used to make fun of me excites to
drive shitty cars because I didn't care
then I got a Tesla and now if I have no
money if my kids are hungry they will
have to go hungry a little longer cuz I
needed it I need I can't I can't ever go
back I can't go back I thought that the
thickness of the steering wheel the heft
of the car the speed my kids are just
gonna be a little malnourished they
won't grow as tall they won't grow to
understand little less potatoes little
less meat yeah maybe no meat for that
was in big trouble you know that they
might default on that loan really you
did didn't you yeah remember they may
not they may not they may get bought out
they mean the lease fire their baby he's
been operating on government subsidies
because the car to make with a car that
I Drive would really be a hundred 25
grand
yeah cuz that battery so expensive but I
yeah but it said there what it was like
60 grams less than that but I couldn't
afford I mean that would be really
expensive otherwise no no horse shadow
would buy it
Porsches coming out with the tesla
killer and it takes 15 minutes to get
250 miles for me it takes almost seven
hours now that's a whole different thing
Porsche knows what they're doing they
know what they'll Tesla very cool check
this out
oh we've been making the best cars in
the world for quite some time
that's it that's adorable nerd now
you'll shoot rockets in this race right
oh [ __ ]
I'll be on 30 though oh yeah everyone's
saying that that's a bummer so you don't
want to sell yours now
Wow it isn't over it's not but whoa all
right
battery life it's all about the
battery's going on with you man you've
added some long days I've worked 14
hours straight yesterday man you're the
headache my stomach if she came back god
damn it I know I did you know up I
didn't throw up um I kind of ate I did I
ate on set and then because have those
meals from Sun Fair which I'm [ __ ]
sick of are ya and talking sick yeah if
you ever have that sure dad yeah I don't
know what it is but also I was talking
to avoid filming this morning I'm like
dude I have my meals off him I'm tired
and standard work stuff like that but
man went up when I'm tired my body goes
sugar sharp yeah [ __ ] them all right I
don't know I think it's your body going
dude forget that stuff let's just get
some simple car yeah simple sugar burn
it off I guess my psoriasis enjoying my
psoriasis let me tell you why is dying
we're both dying or if we don't have
much longer for the first time before
you go first I got my car I see my
stomach I meant to call just flowers
where the bikes are chinputs flowers if
I start five years from now yeah yeah
just two bundles of flowers but I was in
my car Mike what if my stomach problems
a real issue then I do those watch like
Garry Shandling frickin documentary
which hit me pretty hard I'm like what
if I die I started think about all this
weird stuff in my car how bad would that
be the reason you're not gonna dies
because you're starting case you gets
better
yeah and when you get stressed and you
do [ __ ] [ __ ] if it's constant DC I like
this because so my psoriasis I decided
when I eat well so I'm eating mostly
like vegetables lean meats good fats
then I go and eat Chinese food with all
that soy and all that that that sauce
and stuff sodium a lot of sugar in the
stands and the old rice in my mouth is
water would you get Chinese it was
Genghis Cohen it's not a good place nice
cheap cheap Chinese sometimes that's
nice well I went to my boys 18th
birthday we'll talk about that in a
second 989 we're gonna talk about that
those last night that's okay that's
correct
what why they here for me I got I got
some fun stories worth it and and so
when I eat that stuff my psoriasis it
a little read up to been a lot better
right not better was a little read
though if you're not careful so if I eat
[ __ ] food it'll grow it'll glow red and
it's got in and so my it's like hey dude
amen no and I go okay okay take it easy
take it easy
all right just just the one hey okay
okay
I'll stick to seitan and [ __ ] don't
make this rice vegetable sauce that's it
so I got to just keep things calm not a
lot of saturated fat relax
anyway um you're good though 89 years
old
whose birthday party Jack that's my
favorite him up to it and where was he
uh he was at gangs Cohen where he would
eat with Doris Roberts all the time Hall
of Famer dead now I don't know anyone
there yes my boy you guys would know him
from a bunch of stuff
yeah he's and everything uh B et TS he
is fantastic look at him he never lost
his vanity will give you the meanest
hand job inside of 89 looks at me and I
said he said would you get me for my
birthday I said well is it
I said maybe a part of my show he goes
no no he's that excited no don't tease
me like that serious no tease me I go
maybe I'll take you to New York for some
theater Oh New York New York like this
he's his hands display no god I miss New
York
I miss it and then I said he said where
you going this week and I said Florida
cos Florida's where I grew up oh yeah me
he said the most glamorous place in the
world when I was growing up I used to go
and pretend that I was a guest at the
hotel I would sneak in as a boy I would
skip school Lana Turner would be there
people like that I would go up and get
their autograph ahead of all their
autographs and then I lost it all in a
mudslide he is here stories is a story
lorries for days we got to get him
asking people enjoy that I think they
would I like those old-time Hollywood
stories and like growing up oh my God
look at him he play he didn't the
Spaghetti Westerns he was in westerns in
his healthy he's healthy he's 89 not
just healthy he's passionate angry he
cries he gave a speech he goes as a
great that go one of the greatest
writers of all time and one of the
greatest movies of all time said and it
was a hairy man quit
a genius a man said may we never be this
form than Wyndham may we never be
farther apart than we are right now and
was something else something else
actually hasn't okay he always cries he
cries when he says and I saw the movie
and when my god when she came out when
she came out and she was dazzled in
those pearls okay it took my breath away
and he starts to get all emotional it
reminds me of what it is to be alive in
the day the reason he's 89 oh by the way
smoked ate what he wanted he stays alive
with his [ __ ] passion yeah I have my
talent I have my passion which is acting
he died singing he's singing and rights
and rights screenplays and plays and
good play and as well and never stops
and so that need to get his expression
out that need to continue to work is I
mean is everything yeah this is a
Broadway this is a Broadway actor this
is a guy who's never stopped working
this talented as they come Oh does he
does he have a mate or a partner
no no just alone love I love my
apartment Brian I love my apartment he
lived you go there he's right on like
right in the middle of Hollywood you go
he's got plants that have names well
he's being a naughty naughty boy and
these up here these naughty mistresses I
see you're looking at me he waters that
what I can't give them too much water
I'll tell you who do you give them too
much while they rebel on you how I go
Jackie got such a great voice he goes
give me an offer baby give me an offer
and tell me where to be I'm a dime I'm a
phone call away and that's how he is I
got how you to and he's healing in 89 he
kill me oh this is another great story
89 he goes like this I go I'm how you
doing he goes I'm feeling 40 baby the
feelings before he and he was really
sick in Egypt my friend told me he took
him to Egypt tayo tayo who's also
another [ __ ] badass who's their best
soap star forever on General Hospital I
mean and tales that I brought him I
brought him to to Egypt and he was
really sick and I brought the doctor and
the doctor said the doctor asked me how
old is he
and and I heard Jack as he was dying in
the room he goes I don't want to hear it
don't say it out loud and tail goes he's
fine you can go home if he's that vain
he's sick he's not he's a [ __ ] he's a
he's an Iron Horse legend he's a [ __ ]
iron horde you meet him when he drinks
wine to this you keep that white wine
coming and I want ice in it I know it's
a sin bring it anywhere I want a tub he
goes can you can you serve it to me in a
helmet that's how he talks
look appraisee I'll have some component
I've never met this man you know I'd
love you're gonna meet him and you will
love him for you love him to death
he is very broken soon he walks in he
sees Frank Willis mother he walks into
Via Veneto and he walks in and the first
thing he says he's his mother he says my
god you look exactly like Sophia Loren
and you know I worked with her look at
the face on her look at the face and he
comes over any crevices pay her face in
his hand she was loving it and by the
way he's got a cane rest he's got a
dressed up in nine dress it so he
suddenly gentleman that's like your good
thinking there's a tease around this man
no no I dress I dress up yeah you'll
dress up for his sports good and he's
got he's got his mustache and he prays
anthems she's so charmed by him because
he's such an army yeah then he goes look
at that face I can't tell you I can't
believe this face Luke Rockhold and all
those guys are stare at my 50th when you
I mean I'm not my 50th but when I had
that dinner you weren't there yeah Luke
is there and and you know studs and he
comes up to him and he goes is this my
welcoming party it's my God look at
these men he's the greatest
I mean passion and he is never negative
he's always looking look at this I'll
use that you're Jack batts
this is great here he is you meet him
Jim look
look at him scarf 89 he looks damn good
damn right
don't shut up let me see how I'm doing
it so I'm doing this great shop it's a
bother shop that's hilarious
yeah we need you to set up a dinner
later next week ready alright alright
done done you head to Florida
yeah and he's got old school actors
everywhere around him he does I love
that meant there all of the best stories
are the best old-school Hollywood the
glamor days the guy talking about that
she's one of the guys the set designer
for every big movie you can imagine you
remember the ghost in the darkness yeah
okay so he's the set designer of that
and a thousand other movies
he's got stories about shooting in
Africa where where he was they were set
and they're shooting after they needed
warriors the Masai warriors once you go
ahead and bring up the Masai too
expensive too expensive not a man under
65 by the way he's not a man under 65
live on blood and milk they needed Masai
words to duplicate in a movie yeah and
the Maasai are legendary still all right
oh my god
still tall she's oh by the way as Rhys
adenosine said and this is true when the
British wasn't but imprisoned the Masai
they would die
you couldn't it's like you couldn't keep
them in a prison look at them why would
they they're all they would just die
great white sharks that's right he kept
that's exactly how they died and they
were never they were feared slave
traders themselves oh just so you know
so just so you know the Masai were a
very very warlike group of people and oh
by the way
6/6 is not uncommon at all athletic as
[ __ ] my friend lived with them he was a
triathlete he said dude I tried to keep
up with them I tried to keep running
with him not happening he goes I tried
to throw like with them except Spears
and it was but not up until very
recently that you would kill a lion as a
man you're right of past was to kill
align with the spear okay gig oh there's
no [ __ ] joke meanwhile the Masai were
like nah we're not doing it and they're
still living like that some of them so
they had to get the Kikuyu who are who
are another tribe and they were now a
cat version the the Kikuyu were
subjugated by the Maasai for a long time
but then they had their own tribe in
their own their own right and they would
they brought these these Kikuyu
tribesmen and who are warriors and the
white girls who took a look at these
these urban warriors these urban
warriors these six-foot-six
decorated native of those Rumpy Rumpy
that they were all they were all like
what the [ __ ] face down ass cuz their
skin clothes and their muscles and their
shoulders they were like what and all
the white dudes he was telling us we all
felt like just these these little shitty
Europeans with these and they would just
stare at you and how about this he goes
this is kind of crazy so they brought
lions in for this movie from Los Angeles
they brought lions to Kenya from Los
Angeles welcome you paint you need
trained long they need actor yeah now
here's what they need Hollywood Lions
they need holliwell eyes here's a thing
though
Brendon they also needed lions that
would eat humans they needed eyes that
look like they attack and eat humans
well it just so happens that in France
they have what's called man-eaters now
what does that mean they train lions
they feed lines out of dummy bodies
human bodies they hollow out the stomach
and put meat in there so the lion starts
to look at human beings as fool and like
no it's not afraid through that because
you need it when you shoot a movie if
you want a lion to look like it's eating
a person's you need to have a very human
- oh they had they had a man - cages sir
because now my buddy who was responsible
for the set design had to work within
the camera he he'd walk there and
they're just bars and those 400-pound
500-pound watches well they just when
they see you they they stop and they
just look like like you know how a dog
sees it's like like the way I look at a
cake pop and storm correct sir correct
well take a look at when your dog looks
at a squirrel or you hold the ball up in
your dog yeah yeah ears up
just like that and I said I wonder if
you can see that on YouTube but either
way
lion and just stop looking and he said
dude was the eeriest feeling either one
gross scary hey that one because if that
case is gone it comes right at you and
eat your tummy if anything goes down you
should eat your tongue it's like you
know when you go to the zoo
blind so tamed yeah prior nyquil you're
like oh yeah I mean he's scary but well
I've been around Hollywood enough long
enough to I've been around lions where
you walk him on a leash whether they're
right there and they're not gonna do
anything to explain because they're so
yeah there's so demands they're so tame
I should say but mmm that time we worked
with that baboon ah I do the thing was
[ __ ] scary yeah we got us don't look
you in the eye
yeah if you're a girl death and only can
I kiss can trend [ __ ] you yeah it's like
okay yeah yeah now you don't and we all
know you don't work with shrimp on Z but
the ghost in the darkness was about the
two male lions that came right though
and here's the story they don't tell you
about in that movie so the ghost of
darkness is with him yeah Val Kilmer and
Kirk Douglas great movie Michael Douglas
and it was the true story about two male
lions that ate that ate a lot killed a
lot of people as they were laying there
right yeah and actually it killed a lot
of the people that were laying the
railroad and the world will said you
know this is them trying to stop the
British from laying railroad the what
they don't tell you is that the British
actually created these my own leaders
because when the the people that were
working the slaves were working on the
railroad when they would get sick they
just they just leave them by the
riverside because the guys that were
working on there were really bad people
this wasn't like policy but these the
people that were just you know whatever
they just you'd be all sick you just see
I just leave figured out they'd leave
you there yeah did you mean by law and
they could eat my alliance and they
think that's what created this is minds
that had a taste for a meat women eat
and now they were like oh really I mean
cuz typically Lions won't god damn could
there be anything worse than getting
eaten alive by a life you're done you're
done
I think chaka choko stomach first they
grabbed you by the neck II poo they
grabbed about back of the neck
now for me I go in the car
I'm not doing a whole yeah I go I go to
my back and I'm gonna go mission control
um what's your triangle do to a lion can
you get out of lines gonna rip your dick
off but you get no you get for a second
I don't
oh it snows feels good on my tummy oh
yeah no but you're strong take it out
leg no claws into my thighs you get him
in a [ __ ] good triangle he'd be like
what the [ __ ] eats my dick like to take
that he pick you up though get him over
what's this chin that's the story behind
Tsavo Lions a pair of beasts rule
destroy a branch broke shot and killed
December 1890 yep they kill a lot of
people Tigers are the real when Tigers
to become man-eaters they are they are
on its rear though so as many as 135
people I think yes the Lions think about
that fine 35 it's a frenzy
it's a frenzy so fresh so scary I know
that lion a tiger he imagine just in
your in your neighborhood effect there's
two lines on the loose they're eating
people I would I wouldn't leave the
house I'd have a son with it there's no
no we'd shut that place they you know
them comment although they creep they
creep they creep they creep
there's and by the way from what I
understand well I know when Tigers eat a
man they leave the head in the feet so
that's how I feel fine fine the old
sneakers in the head you can see it on
YouTube I don't want to get into it but
you can see what I'm saying if you see
that tiger that eats I gave falls into
the zoo oh yeah
I've seen a few guys buy that's my
grandma oh just like takes off like yeah
[ __ ] yeah well you guys carry note he's
carrying a doll like he's carrying a
doll like he's carrying it all I did I
fell asleep with makeup on my face last
night Brian makeup well you look at like
my gay man yes the truth is be careful
of El Tigre anymore apparently when
those cuckoo yo warriors and the movie
set and they were all kind of like they
wouldn't really talk to anybody and they
the locals the other locals felt like he
said it kind of like they do they
wouldn't talk to the locals they were
like better than them so there's a whole
class structure
and humans of the way with your color
red yeah and they were all like shorter
and they're like yeah and apparently as
the the when the water should at they
created like a lack of morale they
[ __ ] up the workers they were all like
kind of like their body language is like
always suck and then the kikuchiyo took
their swords in there and their i mean
their spears and their they're all
they're accoutrement their shields and
they sold them really yeah they were
like here you go by this office there's
man anyway I forgot I'm really having
this day and age like there's no really
like tigers and lines like that are on a
feeding frenzy cuz now it's like oh one
line killed one person let's hunt him
down and kill him yeah well you can see
come down over you watch masai killing
Lions with Spears they just do it forget
for fun well it was all part of it was
it was part of a rite of passage they
dead they know they're they know their
land they would never do things they
didn't kill the way they don't waste
things they don't do it for fun right
this isn't a safari right sounds like
there's footage of Masai warriors Oh
actually killing oh you're just on a
safari chin and clicked on this one
no it's it's older they're older there
you go oh my god this is oldest [ __ ]
this is this an old movie it's real
though yeah let's try that first one dad
you imagine hunting a wine without does
a pitcher clione up don't give my music
arena hooter
everybody be mother
nod yeah you go to this new more let's
play around you know which you I gotta
help yeah yeah I keep doing that man
that's healthy you got punched up yeah
they get them wave that beautiful skin
is so much better this deadline her look
stays the track route on them and
there's a [ __ ] oh dear he's quit stop
what damn just gonna chop up yeah you
want to keep having this I just don't
like seeing people kill any news like I
I like when they like Eileen Angelo
because it's good but I don't like see I
don't like when people kill beautiful
animals like that people are gonna call
you hypocrite though you know I know but
I like it the lion
I wouldn't needle and so the sport of
killing I don't like right I don't like
trophy hunting personally this is
million the comes to me to saying that
uh mountain lions good meat it's not
it's the worst I talked to Steve Rinella
why did Joe say that Steve Rinella told
us he goes it's the worst meat and
Stevie to everything and Steve Rinella
has eaten mountain lion and and it is
the worst hardest meat you're not
suppose in the Bible even in the Old
Testaments like don't eat leopard or
natural some big cat you nuts with these
things that eat other know their meat
that's right that's right because you'll
get you get all kinds of pathogens like
the chicken is there anything that eats
other meat though no you don't even need
birds of prey you don't even you know
typically you can either sounds really
chickens will eat insects fish will eat
other fish so you can but for the marsh
to eat that eat other fish like tuna
doesn't eat other oh you have to know
there's some fish so you can fish as
they Brendon but of course they live
alone put off compatriots little fries
forced another fish do like you are well
they're not eating [ __ ] help sir no
they're not giant whale shark noting
giant kelp and [ __ ] [ __ ] you man so cat
brains not worked in yeah I thought if
these birds too though remember we saw
the videos of the fish-eating birds
that's like part of some dude but you
don't even tell you don't eat hawk or
Osprey or going on go ahead and try some
Eagle you just [ __ ] you got the hot
sauce anything chickens eat like insects
they're insectivore so you can eat them
but
good meat but it just depends but you
you know the difference you you know and
pigs they stuff right everything pigs
leave everything for the most part they
eat roots in the wild and they don't
know why stay away from swine I'm not a
big pork guy man they kind of disgust me
because pigs you will eat [ __ ] the their
own feces well my pig farmer told me
that they will eat literally anything
you can feed them dead animals crush
[ __ ] out of it and back in the day mafia
guys would use those big boars human
body yeah that's right cuz they they get
rid of everything little you clones had
everything to do lap time time is that
is that your jaw teeth teeth are good
roughage guys you need the teeth because
I will
Hong Kong Kong try think the weirdest
thing I've a of you
my daddy duh monkey brain but that's it
he's at a table that's how you get I'll
do that they said is it an AIDS virus
jumped but they don't know using the
Navy yeah and there I forget where they
were stationed well they used to cut the
monkeys head they put the monkeys head
his brain into a hole in the table ug on
the top of his head he was not in a
million [ __ ] Internet you know I saw
it on faces of death though yeah I don't
know Alan Oh max really she faces of
death my childhood yeah I was terrified
you ready to face the death right or did
you miss that cow I saw it God that [ __ ]
was horrible can drink cobra blood I
know they do that in Vietnam and stuff
the cut the thing I'm just not doing
that [ __ ] I saw some video that's I wish
I could remember someone post I think
Paulie Malignaggi retweeted it but it's
people eating like things that are alive
like it's somewhere in Asia Chen it's
usually in Asia and it's like it's squid
and just move around and the girls all
it's really first like sticking out of
her mouth and then there's like these
all this [ __ ] in japan they'll take its
planet area in japan will take a lobster
they'll pop its shell they'll cut it
until it's so walking around you take
pieces from its tail bring that [ __ ] up
chin I wouldn't do that I don't like
that stuff I don't like I'm not easy but
eating yeah nothing live I don't lights
in Korea there's a white dude eating it
though yeah I don't like it
octopus are really smart young Jin man
fish market we're going to try some Sun
and he speaks cool smart I've spent all
my money and saved it I swear to God
they're so smart you can't bring me to
create Jin I would save that thing oh oh
it seems cool is it because we know now
there do man you know that's not taste
oh that's disgusting that person be able
to do that I would never do that
octopus can see your face and tell if
you're angry or sad they know all this
stuff they're so close I read about that
I mean dead octopus is not live like
calamari no while you two raw still but
my one of my early childhood members
living in Greece was that they would
take the octopus and beat it against a
rock for about an hour and the reason
you do that is to tenderize to tenderize
it it's so it's so hard otherwise and so
you just see the fisherman just boom
beating it against the rocks got that
place in New York ruin it's still the
best restaurant I've ever been to that
Mediterranean Sea clay teas it's a clay
cafe sick ladies I tried posting it face
it when I do it anyways but they was
that that that octopus tentacle that
they just grilled and then olive olive
oil lemon and like rosemary right my
word is correct other than they knew
that you went this is the best thing
I've ever had yeah some of that [ __ ] is
food can be as we just say how we want
to say box plus they know yeah I know
it's hard to say no to anything that
delicious come oh it was the best thing
that's ever been one man that's not bad
for myself a slave would look mr. riah
sits like six multiples yeah really I
don't know I bet you can eat up
I can't no I'm saying it like no I'm oh
I thought you liked it not a fire
doesn't light up he doesn't okay calm
calm
bread's he does breads no breads for the
kid
no breads for the kids I feel so much
better now you're there was kind of a
big push for the the insect protein ran
that I went away yeah my boy my boy had
me doing that the cricket
so it was cricket powder bars I brought
him I brought him on my hunting trip
with Rogen and I brought a bunch of
these cricket its cricket [ __ ] Boris
cricket cricket yes must be really high
in [ __ ] protein first of all the [ __ ]
doesn't it's powdery it doesn't stay and
it sucked those got a guy's teeth are
the worst and I just his teeth are
grosser than the insect and kiss that
guy what do you want to do I got a kiss
that [ __ ] mouth or I gotta eat that
grasshoppers wrapper right now this is
the worst teeth I've ever seen their
terrible teeth yeah
yeah there's like clothes for like
cricket and insect protein isn't work
mealworms yeah yeah that's countries
where food was scarce look at the
maggots oh right good but I you can keep
it oh they're high in protein I'll take
a steak go [ __ ] yourself
liability people do that they trying to
reinvent the wheel dude it's six times
higher then then you know venison good
I'll eat a deer oh good cuz I worked in
hopes Opie cuz yeah I'm malnourished and
Protima I'm deficient protein so I
better find something with extra protein
of stew you know I get extra scoop of
chicken at Chipotle you know what I've
been doing and it's been delicious it's
a little weird for some people but I go
to Japan late I see it white rice and
chicken nothing is nothing wrong just
plain not [ __ ] fantastic I do that
all the time tastic I do it all the time
it's well spice to that that rice is
cilantro lime slice delicious you miss
all the hoopla and it's just a plane
it's easy on my stomach easy on your
tummy feel good easy on your tummy
that's right don't knock white rice and
protein the way all of Asia and Middle
East everybody's white rice is fantastic
brown rice is the culprit
yeah I don't like brown oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
brown rice not good for you no I swear
my sense like Papa Papa that baby up and
go
Zapata's for shoes right that she's in
space right spot to spot to catch any
fool in Spanish yeah that's his main
language and my goblin is he want man
he's like grab my hand guy Han well we
live kind of close to a Starbucks my god
he wants to walk man like why do I like
to like this little dude leaves me right
up to Starbuck yeah he wanted the kids
hot chocolate in there oh yes my kid I
love that I'm like what the [ __ ] oh my
god what are you doing man I'm so in
love with him yeah like I love my wife
around your kid oh she loves them could
you did you see I read her face guys
like she couldn't stop staring I don't
know she just come around Mormon man
well baby said yep I'm not kidding
nobody better babysitter no you made
this fantastic man
goddamn man this vintage oh he's so cute
I love him he's he is not cautious you
can throw a ball at his face and catches
it or it bounces off his face eyes wide
open keeps coming at you rascal rascal
Waymon he'll let you cut his nails let
you do jump off the couch she'll just go
balls to the wall who grab a hose
squirting his face he's zero fear yeah
unless you're trying to cut his hair he
has this afro right now and I gotta get
that today I've been dreading it all
Samson he hates Samson and you can't cut
his hair I can't have that just do it
it'd be hilarious he's done Oh buddy
goes out like this he looks like that
painter Bob you know that guy's that's
what he looks like
I love it I think it's so funny that you
think you're white hey no I mean come on
dude you know who's making me laugh so
hard was that uh Tom Segura's wife
we're backstage first of all I have to
follow her she destroys us how the
heritage turkeys destroyed we gotta get
her on podcast I know she was coming
here when this first came out anyway
she's pregnant as [ __ ]
babies do think in July super pregnant
this she is God and she was make me
laugh so hard in the back man really oh
my god she's so funny
oh she's so she's just she goes Brandon
ah I need a little advice I'm gonna go
out there is it cool if I start with
this and I'm not gonna say the word she
was saying I was laughing so hard
she's I just always want to get there's
been like
what's up beep I was laughing so she's
pregnant
[ __ ] she's so pregnant so funny man yeah
whenever something's showing off
whatever words early you're not allowed
to say but every human being when coming
from her low I was laughing so hard like
I wouldn't do that out there
shake now come on the new co-op next to
make you look something no no please
don't
oh she's got a great sense she's
hilarious and her and time but I was
talking to her I go how do you guys
manage it because you know in my
household I'm the only comic cuz you're
on the road you know there's you only
comic nasal well she's married to Tom
Segura
they're both killers these comics both
huge success podcasts and how do you do
it as far as like with your son like the
wreaths getting hard to leave I have all
these dates I dread it when I leave my
son when I come back he's even different
and she goes well now I that man my
management knows this
I won't leave for longer than 48 hours
40 hours is the limit for me she goes
and she goes in this coming up here I'm
only doing theater so I do one night in
um hope how do you want the Adamo good
for her
she was top she was Tommy though I said
get the check I sent his house down the
road because I sent his that something
the road out there make some money but
yeah she was the way we deal is we don't
you know we're never to both on the same
weekend and I'm only gone now for one
night and before with the kid when he's
little 48 hours good that'd be such a
beast man off the two traveling college
trying to figure out the schedule and
she does she is there what she's not me
she's well she's gorgeous
yeah Tom's doing a movie shooting a
movie Atlanta he is now yeah what's he
doing I'm not sure some County and land
I guess she said he's always wanted to
do it so I was like I haven't seen Tom
around the Comedy Store I haven't seen
him really anywhere she's like oh he's
been shooting a movie so funny she's
hilarious
Podcast is so funny I haven't heard it
in your mom's house I have it set up in
the house it's great yeah Tom Segura my
favorite people on planet earth he's a
great guy lost a lot of weight yes he
did seems to be keeping it off too and I
think he's shot as special for Netflix
in a denver again
handsome kid look at him the
why don't me say before he was a big boy
you love him some Florida [ __ ] yeah
freeze what team he loves he look II
know sports though that's all was it
that's him without the bed sure is oh
sure their kids cute as [ __ ]
mmm super cutie mmm we have some friends
like the kids call it like it is not
everyone can be cute no the world's not
fit alright world ain't fair bro ain't
fair ah Jesus Christ League that Tom's
you are thrilled Jim what do you been up
to just that San Francisco trip huh
pretty much any other trips coming up no
not for a while
I mean that trip landed on the day the
biggest time a weekend of all so I don't
want to do a bonus podcast first time I
couldn't do it yes I was gonna say
before I forget come out to the West
Palm Beach improv this tomorrow Friday
Saturday or Tuesday Freddie said it
where's that restaurant Restoration
Hardware leather crop you cannot miss it
okay so you got your hotel here which is
my favorite hotel stay at that it's the
hotel yeah and then where we stayed last
yeah and then in between you know the
shopping center
yeah right in the middle island there is
literally the biggest Restoration
Hardware you've ever seen in life yeah
and the top is Russian Hardware
restaurant yeah oh it's a Restoration
Hardware restaurant it's not another
restaurant it's on being restoration I
love it there oh Jesus I thought I did I
just hung on Restoration Hardware
nothing wrong with that the entire time
I just hang out chill on the couch hey
hey coffee
yep I'm a coffee guy man mommy to man
like that funny guy I love it me too now
uh how's your tummy right now fine yeah
yeah fine more hungry more fun have you
eaten I don't mean this morning I mean
I've been eating the morning so no
syllable but in your oatmeal
oh god you asked me what I put I called
the big brown oatmeal guy she's gonna
[ __ ] on your own meal you ready yeah
I still can't wait steel cut oats yeah I
put a scoop of almond butter in it not
bad once stevia not matte and then I
take walnuts and shaved almonds and I
mix those in and I top it with
blueberries every morning okay I'm very
your turn I'm okay thank you
now what I do is I get my steel cut oats
standard yeah yeah I'm a cans those come
in a steel quick oats that that oxidize
the sugar right away you [ __ ] rolled
oats you [ __ ] we don't with my steel
cut oats which which the berserks which
the Scottish Highlanders would eat and
then and then I and then I take it out
let it sit for a second then I'll take
some I'll take some ground-up walnuts
yeah
and and then I'll take I'll take some
blueberries yeah okay
and you know what sometimes maybe some
organic raspberries but I don't have
together I don't have to go okay but
then what those don't fit in oh then
what I'll do is I'll take them some
powdered some powder some ground flax
seed and chia seeds I'll take a couple
scoops that and add those in the not
done not done then I take couple scoops
of ham seeds throw that in the fresh
hemp seeds mix that all around
I [ __ ] eat that down oh wait I'm
sorry Fleur to put stevia not me I'll
put some real on April syrup I don't
give up oh wow maple syrup I'm get are
you trying to get diabetes no I'll just
do a little drizzle it I call it
Drina Stevie goes longer an open eye
color your twizzle that doesn't flare up
your psoriasis no nope do you love it
I've kind of forgot about your
Invisalign how's it feeling let me see
your teeth it's coming together are they
or no they're not really coming together
doing nothing
my second tray bro give it give it some
time did they start tighten it up as he
passes passes apparently you know you
know it's working cuz it's doing but
what if they got it isn't working what
if they got it wrong we'll know soon I
got this is my second tray I got I've
only got 12 more to go go go go
you wear a monthly program every week
you change every ten days as you go in
can't wait for it to be done really but
I do like chewing on my on the rubber
when it let us get veneers
they're not recipients don't straighten
your teeth veneers just make your teeth
white and my teeth are pretty white yeah
and what [ __ ] world no teeth white
listen don't go on your teeth boy pull
back your head don't go like you acted
like you just saw like a bunch of
decapitated heads don't go like that
don't ever do that again in my teeth are
and people or fiduciaries do my stand a
bit go let me see your teeth bro and I
gotta know if they're not that bad cuz I
writing up runs the job is a bad person
your teeth are 50 shades of yellow now
these shades of yellow yeah ether now
what I VIN ears I feel like there's a
thing to do right see a lot of people
veneers veneers are terrible because
they look like veneers left they're good
ones mmm they usually it's very hard to
match like the natural tone of your skin
so what happens is you look like you
have really white teeth ain't and that
you don't want that and your lips
we do what I need to have a talk about
your teeth your top teeth are simply I
know my bottom well both Baba know my
because my teeth are so much better
that's hold on do you think you're
better me can you envision I got teeth
your teeth ish hey chin my shame micro
watch this coming through these are
[ __ ] better here you go
let's just every time you have braces if
I'm come please come here let's just
take the top teeth no no it's a Polish
my knees you shut up let's take his top
teeth hi-yah now take a look at those
take a look at those your mouth oh
really
look oh come on chin hold on let me see
your kitchen look at how high look at
how high that little shitty teeth like
that yeah [ __ ]
you have a black now move your bottom no
hold on go like this this tooth is blah
no it's not that Jesus good [ __ ] don't
be so [ __ ] neutral bro you know what
I'm saying like babe huh they look alike
but you're talking about the actual ah
no my front teeth are my top your top
are 100% better than here I've never
said you're talking to my your bottom
teeth let me see your bottom she's so
bad no that's not sure I have one shitty
[ __ ] tooth are you [ __ ] me see look
at your teeth are all righty they're all
bunched up right now your teeth are you
do
this I'm not talking I gotta put this is
Brian see oh what am i tray back in hey
geez I wanted us work these guys putting
in [ __ ] scissors retire hey wait we got
we got oh my god
show us the celebrities with bad teeth I
just this is ones with veneers
oh oh oh more look how much well look
how much better she looks yeah let me
see Demi Demi can we get a closet that's
real is it yeah it's real yep that's
real all right I'm gonna Tom Cruise
whatever where's my thing with veneers
I've been looking into it lately if if
you even there's what happens to your
original teeth because your base putting
caps on your original teeth ah they like
disintegrator they just get like that I
don't know I didn't have to shave him
down I don't feel good no this cage oh
my god his teeth were like yours
yeah oh jeez what do you want veneers or
what are we doing here look how pretty
they look right now I don't care why you
don't do that broken to the last stop
for your bottom ones I'm not doing it
the dude awakened veneers hey man
you'd fully redeem I am a comic all
right look at that
why not George custom veneers didn't he
why not veneers no lately have you
yeah you too yeah why not we need to
straighten the bottom we need to bring
the bottom one down a little bit but you
know that no no you know that
let's bring the bottom of day yeah
braces as we're stalking no but I need
you you're probably gonna have to get
into Invisalign you know that right
never doing a Miss actor first now get
veneers I've already looked it without a
doctor on Instagram who specialized okay
but you you also may need to straighten
things up a little bit as aunt where
they do all that bro huh they can do all
that with the veneers I love I love
what's her name here dude something
about her I've seen her in person
something about her eyes and she's
physically I used to work out next to
her first of all beast beast in the
world LP son who's got a tail piece on
did I see it yeah yeah a lot of time I
show my rages in the georgeous she's
[ __ ] gone
just gorgeous you're right Jim would you
do veneers yeah probably not JT start
winning awards either brother they're
not bad not great I got to be honest
they probably come out a little bit if
you have an oversight you know hey you
know you have an overbite but I think I
Drive over the nun Durr I don't look
like a bulldog let's go to some current
events damn it
dumb sure well I figure eat up off it
depresses me
I feel like gin was just a second here
ridiculous I might have to compromise my
house and everything else for that
situation I'll do it up
I think it's nice knowing you sure I got
enough for her chin she okay she's
gorgeous
an event man all right man okay so this
one reminded me of that teacher you had
she had like no nose or something mrs.
roach yeah so he'll down and died oh
well this one was on a show called this
morning and it's like a British TV show
and then she pulled off her nose without
like warning anyone do you guys want to
see it oh I can't
okay you can't I can't watch you
understand I'm sorry I was reading the
hot girl on the right I missed all that
[ __ ]
what happened that girl on the right is
delicious kid what happened so this lady
she lost her nose he got taken in by a
dog that black girl is so hot she's oh
she lost her nose yeah she lost her nose
by a dog just like a pet dog actually
bumping his head into her nose one time
and she thought it was broken the doctor
said it wasn't broken
six months later started swollen up she
treated all the nerves and it developed
some sort of autoimmune disease
oh my so she'll have to remove her nose
so she was on this morning show and she
just sort of just pause we took it off
let me see it's a little scary there it
is very tough I've seen this but I bet
she breeds like a [ __ ] though I
bet her I bet shean just breathe in like
never before so they're held together by
magnets
oh yeah
damn you the cartel is amazing yeah I'm
sure looks good Mike hold on my teacher
didn't have that she had a juicy cavity
in her facial juicy don't put gauze in
there poor woman poor kids I'm in sixth
grade I'm [ __ ] terrified to go to
history that makes me so sad to see that
all right she looks good though with
that prosthetics amazing sure you can
not tell I just want them to grow nose
it's like come on come up with I'm
jealous skip I would love to pop off my
toes and breathe just a deep breath I
have so much [ __ ] ah it is for us to
just be disfigured I have such a thing
it's good for her though I mean it's
good that she is that prosthetic that's
amazing she lived normal lives my buddy
Jerry McFadden does not take care of
himself and I go he was just drinking
and eating food and I had gout and I go
um you have a cancer in your family
because I sure do all through my family
tree in fact we get kinds of things like
that that wine bottle in your nose we
get tumors like that so do do do more
wine please
well Cheryl no fear at all Buffalo Bills
like I Richie incognito oh yeah Oh
health issues yeah what kind of helped
is just phenomenal your liver kidneys
are failing
oh no this stress is Jonah from football
from football liver kidneys from all the
painkillers I don't know whatever it is
giant
typically it is don't huge guys who are
300 something pounds like that all
muscle don't they kind of break down
they do but a lot I mean those guys
played were just as big as him if not
bigger and played a lot longer he's glad
late for walkies he got drafted with
Klopp they're both rookies in st. Louis
so that's 2006 I said 12 years yeah so
he has got six so ten to watch he took
many squats in the 8th he's a huge man
yeah the novel football player yeah the
captain Buffalo Bills was a beast with
the Rams beast in Miami I told you man
Piven saw him pick a guy up or spike him
yeah or or hopefully he's smart with his
money now but at the time he was living
paycheck to paycheck game game check -
game check yeah Wilin out great guy
though
yeah he's the guy who I tried to shake
his hand in my hand didn't go all the
way around his palm I'm not joking
did you understand what I'm saying yeah
so his palm is the length of my hat
right no so see how my so for me if you
go for my wrist to the end of my longest
finger that's how thick his palm is so I
couldn't put my hand around his palm I
wonder what he's gonna do that isn't
that weird yeah that is just fat
I wonder what are you gonna do now does
he save me no he says a carrot made a
lot of money I hope he's okay when you
see your kidneys and liver are shutting
down what does that mean what does that
fun painkillers really let me he'd be
yeah but he was you know he party are
too so who knows [ __ ] okay
and then he joked around with this
agency well sort of joked to Jamie I
fired two layers all right little
kitchen Nick Diaz his suspect he took a
sink he took a suspension for a year and
then that's gonna be up this April 19th
so he'll be free to fight after you I
need word on John Jones no matter what
Nick Diaz right no I know but isn't the
same thing what's going on with that I
don't think there's any new word no huh
yeah find out but with Nick Diaz I tell
you what I wouldn't mind seeing him
force Bisbee Bisbing satisfied if his
being wants to fight or mine that I'd be
huge oh how about some of my gas lon
why I don't know he's a really good
striker and like to see that they seem
to fight similar styles him and Nick
I mean Nick's not gonna come out and
fight Kevin Gausman he's gonna fight his
super fast super fight you fight a big
names in his name yeah yeah he's like
gonna fight us going for the money yeah
it's a goddamned I was reeling be I hear
you but no he's a finally cab is being I
mean something a big name someone with a
very strong it's not like he's gonna
start from the bottom I've worked his
way up mister you Nick Diaz this show
hopefully gets a big fight it'd be cool
if it came back cool they could use them
I wanted out it's kind of different lay
of the land I worked in a draw lead be
being gone for a long time long time
long time even be even GSP wasn't the
same drawn one thought
he's got four years Nick's been gone for
quite some time yeah
how old is Nick probably I'll look it up
36 he's up there 30 before he's younger
than I thought
yeah he's way too young and I thought
here's the question is even wanna fight
yeah he teas right there he I picture he
posted a picture saying back where I
left back where we left off interesting
shift the money's right to do it just
like his brother you know I don't think
they're foaming at the mouth the fight
but if the money's right the matchups
right he'll do it mm-hmm
so they've offered his brother Nate a
ton of fights but if Nathan for that
Conor fight it's he's me waiting for
quite some time that would be cool if we
came back what does she get chin uh you
know Mark Zuckerberg has been in front
of the Senate for a while trying to
explain that whole data collection thing
he was using a four-inch cushion on his
chair to prop him up see this one her
funny people care because he's using
like these tricks these tricks to be you
know have more stature and if you look
at his older pictures he always frames
it in a way that he looks taller than
than what he really is so you just use
the little tricks to trick people he's
five seven yeah hmm I mean he's
self-conscious but also who gives a [ __ ]
how big you are you own Facebook oh why
why is even carrying what would you
fight I think you always feel yeah and
shopping it yeah sure guys do that where
it's hard yeah my mother is a kid we
used to say I just hope you're tall I
was like teased it's a good thing I got
I'm kind of tall or at least I'm not
sure you're not short you know you're
not sure you're right yeah you I'm
taller than average time yeah you never
saw live 9 so I'm almost six feet
exactly so you know but I mean what if I
hadn't been five seven well yeah the
doctor told me you know the doctor whole
time the doctor told me I was gonna be
five seven you know five six five
seventy when I was a kid
he measured mile mi im3 he measured my
thigh bone Sal - am I gonna be I was a
kid it's silly I was so depressed I was
so I've cried the doctor guaranteed my
son my mother were 6 to nothing huh the
doctor can guarantee that our son will
be over 6 - the sun's going to be a
giant I went maybe it's awfully early to
call sir now they know you'd ever know
them no you don't though with your son
your son is a little shorter than me
right huh yeah thank you that's it yeah
I guess if you're sure that it would be
your cup you know that never goes away
even if you have 10 to Gillian dollars
but it's also like a mental thing it's
it's something for people like stature
so it actually helps his business if
people think he's this that's not true
theory but it's not I'm not sure people
have a hiring interview anymore and more
in first class yeah that's true I'm
saying Mark Zuckerberg yeah but you know
like interviews there's tricks a you do
too if you're if you get higher than
your interview interviewer and it's not
good you're supposed to sit lower or
something like that
god I don't know you all right so
Brendan I think you'll be better at
describing this whole stuff the Tristan
Thompson thing who is dating Chloe
Kardashian or actually with you in two
weeks
yeah doing two weeks the of the video
here isn't you have kids with Lamar Odom
there's a couple yes this is our first
child the Skarin TMZ broke the story
Thompson was seen making out touching
and motorboating two women back in
October whoo collabs in Washington DC
all right girls they do look pretty hot
oh wow so making out with one of them
oh man how about that one knows that the
cameras on yeah it's a hookah lounge
hookah lounge in Washington DC
scroll up let me see this quote one of
the alleged acts from tryst read oh hell
up keep going up hold up he gets around
what's this wait keep going huh let me
read the story the golf gin yeah so says
a woman claimed she spent the night to
come to New York through this weekend
posted it quickly do
sex tape and number of raunchy tapers
with NBA all-stars the woman who goes by
whatever on this game claims she's the
one who was seen in video say night
walking him in a hat in four seasons
with Tristan
Tuesday night she filled her IG story
alleged text from true why is she doing
some videos of couple having sex on an
[ __ ] but she claims just her interest
in what a [ __ ] play for me like God
your dog booted you what's wrong with
her
it's late J you want his on my first
though you know what what would you get
out of it with your her that booty looks
so fake temper fake but what kind of
tension that's gonna get you well you
know they have all those people just a
snakes in there by the video shitty time
impossible absolutely this is all this
is this isn't [ __ ] you can't prove [ __ ]
well you know would you say there they
are walking in together to a hotel again
oh that looks so good tonight those
jeans of spandex that's my problem this
video is this her yeah you could tell by
the but damn son went to their hotel
room that's kind of right not to do that
actually that's you can sue someone
stalking yeah I'm not mad at that ass
really you know what it looks real from
here now it's closer that [ __ ] looks
real real nice Jen don't hate I'd love
to see that video then she posed video
though they said quickly deleted know
what's it's out there though people
would get it damn she is financed oh
pretty face for sure hell yeah
scroll down chin so one of the ledge
text of scroll up one of the ledge text
from Tristan read if I was there I would
grab you while you try to walk away from
me then I would pull your hair and kiss
you then rip your clothes off and lay
you down watch suck your [ __ ] and say
sorry
oh good nothing I haven't said in one
way or another and my in my [ __ ] 51
years take it easy Tristan yeah to me
leave the man alone I don't get anything
any pleasure organic for watching
somebody who got caught [ __ ] up but
what I want to know is there's not
there's nothing here ok so that's yeah
you know it was the security guards girl
how do you know you know I'm not saying
I believe that he didn't get his dick
out and yeah put it between those
perfect cheeks and that beautiful face
all I'm saying is there's not much to go
on here yeah just that one
black-and-white video of them inside the
hookah lounge yeah that was it I mean
now now how come the hookah lounge is
allowed to make that public
so installs they must have been some
shady cuz she was waving at it you can
see her doing that but also says here
multiple reports say the woman near to
Tristan's the IG model named Lonnie
Blair
uh it appears she might have no
involvement it was merely trolling
Tristan to Chloe
so she's just trying to [ __ ] things up
which is the baby what a bad person
yeah she should I don't know say New
York Washington DC okay and that history
on models not the one the whatever the
other one was says that she might have
pretended I always know but my video
[ __ ] off its weak so my friends beware
of professionals like girls like that
you should be able to sniff them out
yeah especially if you mean I can tell a
mercenary a lot of - there's a mercenary
yeah like I think there i g p+ Tristan
Thompson and girls won't get famous
because you're dating Khloe Kardashian
yeah they know you know if they thing in
the middle and [ __ ] that up there you
get attention one way or the other
yeah yeah cuz you get you get hit up bad
blood there yeah hello really mmm if
you're Tristan Thompson I think he's a
good-looking dude tall yeah millionaire
yeah giant dick like this Mike you know
there's a million reasons people are not
everyone's a rich and you look like that
okay yeah oh and you're connected
Kardashians me suck in that day sorry
but what else you got you got some legit
pity or somehow I'm trying to see this
sex tape I don't we did you know that
Floyd's bodyguard for him in with his
bodyguard got shot why does some random
group of people were chasing down his
entourage the bodyguard entourage and
shot into their truck and he actually
shot in the leg did they his body girls
are so big did this guy got shot
wow he said that guy probably find or
yeah they shot him and then did they
think Florida's no they were like
targeting that entourage of party guards
wow I wonder what's going on there I'm
sure there's some backstory there Floyd
has the biggest on trust I've ever seen
apparently he needs it [ __ ] Wow well
that's great
not too many other cool stuff oh this
guy remember this dude that did the
swatting no so this guy did a swatting
call which is like calling someone's
house saying oh there's a guy with a
bomb or something and then the SWAT team
comes right yeah doing risk and
sky perfectly normal that yeah it's
weird what do you say about him so that
in that original story the guy was
killed by the cops innocent guy to open
the door yep but then this guy somehow
was able to tweet from jail and this is
what he tweeted this is one of his
accounts he goes how am I on the
internet if I'm in jail oh because I'm
an e God that's how and then he goes all
right now who's talking [ __ ] you're
asked about to get swatted so what
happened was I guess there's a inmate
kiosk and the vendor had changed it
accidentally to where this guy found out
how to get in there and get onto the
Internet Jesus you're not doing should
enjoy prison time that's not [ __ ] no
attitude I got him in a ones what do you
got well sort of make boxing did you
know what Manny Pacquiao and Freddie
Roach is not working together on his
next fight what yeah why
apparently Freddie thinks he should stop
Freddie's upset about how Manny's doing
boxing and doing the senator stuff at
the same time you know yeah yeah Freddie
Manny heard that story and then he said
he's not working with them so he's
working with another coach for that one
oh it's the end of the road for Manny
anyways that's a great fight I think
it's weirdly Freddie Roach with a bad
idea yeah but we had this stage of the
career it's like whatever man little
sketch in Brock Lesnar so he's signed a
deal with W here e signed with w e but
there's a clause saying he have one
fight in the UFC this was saying out and
below the belt yesterday while filming
this is one of our topics and I said
everyone's freaking out over they needed
Brock rocks done well well no you can do
both it's not exclusive deal so to have
one giant fight I'm openness John Jones
I'd be an interesting fight huh I think
I think for Brock it's either John Jones
could be a terrible matchup for him so I
don't know if Brock would do why Robert
just get in his face there's a fire John
would just take him down and beat the
[ __ ] out of him take him down yeah
thinking that really yep taking that
hits keep distance for a long time and
pick them apart on the feet and then
take him down trouble that's like aa
trip
but so I don't think Brockton take that
bite
I see Brock versus Francis and got it
that's an interesting thing to say swing
for the fences but then Brock would just
tackle them get him on the ground
yeah but it's this big kind of you know
can Brock get them down can France land
a punch you know whoever does the lanes
first it's over as far as if there's
takedown each screw if Brock at city
screwed yeah you could that post would
be sick yeah the good fight for Brock
you know so it's as almost a saber fight
to mark hunt brockless Marc Cohn that's
to talk about I'm Viking mark not as
good
you know takedown defense and is you
know a very experienced Francis she's a
show us Brock Lesnar in high school
wrestling look at how big he was there
it's exactly the same yeah so one of the
biggest freaks of our life that man you
can barely see there is look at that
neck kids right Jesus bro good no you
look at him in college college is stupid
now in college what's that called shun
yeah that's called she got lace look at
him because GPS she got beat by that
that Neil Dave never played football zyk
you know what let me go be the starting
left guard for the New England Patriots
and he did it I'm a Brock fan man I'm
not fan of that hair cap I'm broadband
he looked really innocent high school
fake as strong as it gets good luck
being that guy is that it Jen that's
pretty much it I think well do you want
to see a cruise ship hit it doc sure
like a giant one yeah Honduras it's like
you know the doc tup was the blows the
the captain doing just nodding off some
[ __ ] yeah I don't know if these are
electronically like guided but I think
the cut the captain does have to guide
it in by himself so they just made a
mistake calculation I think's coming
kind of hot - [ __ ] you know heavy those
things are
boats are fascinating now we cook and
then now it gets the dog
and destroys
I probably [ __ ] the ship up at all
that's solid steel
now that's give me a favor this weekend
buddy
what I'm gon go see a quiet place please
and then call me I will see you Friday
night thank you let me go Friday night
thank you
if you don't you've hyped it up so
what's a great movie I know you don't
shut up that's a great move you're gonna
move you know a lot of times I feel like
everything's good I want you to see it
on Toby it's a great movie I'm gonna see
a Friday night dude scram oh I'm gonna
see it okay we're in West Palm I mean
yeah let me there yeah yeah I'll get
this from you I saw quiet place holy
[ __ ] I know you will get up yeah don't
go to that Restoration Hardware
restaurant I will come see me this
weekend for God's sake tomorrow Thursday
Friday Saturday I'm at the West Palm
Beach improv I look forward to seeing
you guys I can't oh hey my buddy Ryan
loco who did he's like one of the best
photographers in the world took all my
pictures you want you want to snap some
shots you bright you need some okay
solid yeah yeah
oh go come come get me Alma Shh I'll
send you is know about this he's
literally here my fears freshly died I'm
ready it's not it's not died is it it's
a terrible day job I know I got I got
West Palm Beach then next weekend is
flora Boston and then we got Denver the
weekend after that come see me boom
close to casino next Friday Saturday but
Calgary's Yuk Yuk's all those shows were
almost sold out less than 50 tickets
left for all the shows Yuk Yuk's Calgary
Friday Saturday 2 shows Friday to show
Saturday and then in may we have West
Nyack those tickets will go on sale any
day now and then we just added Minnesota
whenever cities at the Mall of America
I'm going there so that will be
announced next week as well
West Nyack Minnesota next week and in
June I'm in Houston that's all you got
for now next week Calgary Yuk Yuk's get
them tea pack a Dom for Bryan myself
this is the fired kid
we're out